-You look great.
-Nice to be here.
-Welcome back.
I wanted to apologize to you
straight up
because I --
Crypto started to crash.
-Uh-huh.
-You know,
It's crashing now or whatever.
And I went up to you earlier
and I was like,
"You must be bummed,"
because I thought
you told me about crypto."
-No.
-It was not you.
-No, but we've spent
the last five years being, like,
sort of shamed about crypto.
Like, "You got it?"
"No."
"You're a coward?"
"No, yeah."
"You're stupid?
You're a stupid coward?
You didn't get crypto?"
And then it's been sort of
crashing the past couple months,
and I got to say, it's been
pretty satisfying to watch.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
Watching crypto crash is like
watching the Fyre Festival
from a nearby boat.
-People are reacting very
positively to your special,
"Blocks," on Netflix.
Congratulations.
-Thank you very much.
-Do you...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Do you pay attention
to what people say
about you on social media?
-Well, you've got to be careful
on social media, as we all know.
For men, it's a lot of --
The social-media influencers
for men are all --
I call them "the clappers,"
because they start all their
posts like this --
like, "What's up, guys?"
If you're under 30,
I just have to let you know,
no one's ever clapped
and said anything great.
JFK wasn't like, "Ask not what
your country can do for you..."
-You're going on tour
next year, buddy.
-Yeah.
-That's a big deal.
-Thank you.
-Do you have someone
watching the house?
-I have someone -- My friend
Sarah watches the house.
And she was watching it
this year when I was on tour.
And I have, like, a small pool,
and I had raccoons back there.
And my first instinct was like,
"You got to, like, kill them."
-Yeah, of course.
-And then she sent me video,
and they're so cute.
I don't --
Can you show the video?
-You brought the video of
raccoons in Neal's backyard.
Take a look at this.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
Oh, my gosh.
They're just
cleaning themselves?
I mean, stop.
-I think you got to
let them stay.
-You've got to keep them.
-Right?
-Yeah, you got to keep 'em.
-And someone goes, "Are you
worried about getting rabies?"
I was like, "They're not going
to give me rabies.
They might give me wabies."
-Wait. Because that's how
cute they are?
-They're so cute,
they're going to give me wabies.
And I'm going to have to
call 911 and be like,
"I think I have wabies."
They're like, "They're going to
send a wambulance over."
And I'm going to go to
the hospital,
and they're gonna go like,
"Do you have insuwance?"
And I'm going to go, "I have
Bwue Cross and Bwue Shield."
-That's how cute
those raccoons are.
-They're that cute.
-They make you talk like a baby.
You know, you talk
about dating in your stand-up.
How's dating life going?
-If you have to ask,
it's not going great.
-That's true.
-Well, alright, the women I date
have always kind of, like --
kind of bossed me around
a little bit.
I think they see me as,
like, a fixer-upper.
Like I'm looking for a coach,
you know?
So they would constantly be
telling me like --
They'd always say like,
"I trained him.
I taught him."
Which is like --
You ever hear a guy say that?
No, because you don't know
any pimps.
So, and then, like, women
would tell me what to do,
and then you talked about this
on the show recently.
I had a woman that I was dating.
We didn't even live together.
She made me get rid of
a piece of art,
and then no one believed me.
And then you talked about it on
the show, and I'm so grateful.
Please --
-I have a clip
of me talking about this here.
-I love Buddy Holly
and I also love stained glass.
-Okay.
-And I don't know why
it just came up,
and he's like,
"You love stained glass?"
And he said something like,
"Do you like Buddy Holly?"
I go, "I do, actually."
He goes, "I have a stained-glass
portrait of Buddy Holly
that my wife is like, 'There's
no way we're keeping this
in the living room.'"
So, I go, "I will borrow it,
and whenever you need it back,
I will hang it in my office."
And it's been in my office
since "Late Night."
Neal Brennan,
if you need it back, I have it.
That's you.
Yeah, it was your girlfriend,
not your wife.
-Yeah.
-But either way, I have it.
It's been in my office, and...
-I feel like,
if I could get it back...
My girlfriend that
I'm dating now is here.
Like, we could maybe --
We could bring it out?
And we can...
[ Drumroll ]
-Can we show it?
Can we bring it out?
Come on over.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
This has been with me
for almost 15 years now.
I can't believe that someone
didn't want this
in their living room.
-I know.
And I feel like I'm in
a good place in my life.
Isn't that cool?
Like, I'm in a good place
in my life and I can --
-You can tell by the silence
how cool it is.
-It's really --
There's a reverent silence
for how cool this is.
So, I feel like
I'm in a good place --
-Can I ask you this, though?
'Cause it has been mine.
I don't want to lose it.
I love it so much.
-Alright.
-Where did you get it?
-I got it in the street
in England.
-That's even cooler.
I love it even more.
-I know.
-You got this on the street
in England,
and now it's lived in
my office for 15 years.
-Yeah.
-And now I'm
giving it back to you.
'cause I'm a man of my word.
-Well, let me just --
My girl is here.
And I feel like
we're in a good place
and I can sort of
make my decisions.
Val, will you stand up? Yeah.
My girlfriend. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, babe, what do you think?
Can we keep it?
-No, it's gross.
-Yes! Exactly. Yes!
It's mine again! Thank you!
She's a keeper.
I love her, by the way.
Neal Brennan, everybody!
His special,
"Neal Brennan: Blocks,"
is streaming now on Netflix.
We'll be right back with
a performance from Wizkid.
Stick around.